Speaker 1: Whatever you think is eventually going
to happen in the 2024 primary. Trump's lead is
exploding in multiple polls. This is the reality
of the situation right now. Is it early? Yes. Can
things change? Yes. Is Trump's main opponent a
guy who hasn't even declared a candidacy yet? Ron
DeSantis, meaning that the numbers may not really
tell us everything we need to know? Absolutely.
But Trump's February polling bump simply cannot
be denied. You know, one of the things they will
often say is we should look at an average of polls
rather than any one poll, if you're going to look
at one poll. Ideally, it will be a highly rated
pollster, not the seed or unrated pollsters of no
a good reputation. Ideally, we would if we look at
one poll, it would be a highly rated pollster. But
in a perfect world, we would look at a number of
highly rated polls and take a look at the average
trend lines and say, What does this tell us in
general? Well, looking at a bunch of new polls,
Donald Trump is expanding his lead, but DeSantis
hasn't announced. Here's an Axios article that
summarizes it for new polls show Trump has
received a boost in Republican support,
with one survey showing him hitting 50% support
in a crowded field. Could it be the visit to the
train derailment site in East Palestine, Ohio?
Maybe. Could it be his campaign stops in South
Carolina? I don't know. But here are the numbers.
New Emerson poll has Trump leading DeSantis by
3055 to 25. That used to be a 26 point lead in
January. That same poll shows Trump getting a four
point bump to 5525. Trump gets 72% support among
Republicans with a high school degree or less.
That same poll found Trump ahead of Biden 4642
but DeSantis trailing Biden. Other polls New
Yahoo News YouGov poll has Trump with an eight
point lead on DeSantis 4739. In the last one,
DeSantis was ahead, so that went from a four point
DeSantis lead. Wrong Desanctis A DeSantis lead was
four. Now it's Trump plus eight. That's a 12 point
swing in a short period of time. You then have
the Republican polling firm Echelon Insights finds
Trump ahead of DeSantis by 1546 to 31. Last month,
Trump was only up by two. So that's a 13 point
gain for the failed former president. And then
in the first Fox News presidential primary poll,
remember, Fox News polling is actually quite good.
Fox itself doesn't do the polling, a pollster
does it? But these are Fox News branded polls.
They find Trump ahead of DeSantis by 1543
to 28. A number of important caveats here.
In general, Trump does better when the
polls just say if it's Trump or DeSantis,
who do you want? When the polls say if it's
Trump or DeSantis or Nikki Haley or Ted Cruz
or Tim Scott or Mike Pompeo or Mike Pence or
Sarah Palin, the more people that are included,
the smaller Trump's lead is. And sometimes
DeSantis is actually still ahead in those
polls that include multiple candidates. So this
is why Trump knows it's actually better for him
for there to be more candidates. If there
are more candidates, he does better in the
polling. Okay. Now, is it possible that this
polling bump for Trump prevents Ron DeSantis
from announcing anything? Is it possible Ron
DeSantis will look at these numbers and say,
Well, Trump built a lead. He added four points,
eight points, sometimes double digits over me over
the last month. Is this a sign I shouldn't even
get involved? It's hard to say because privately,
if you're Ron DeSantis and big Republican donors
are coming to you and saying, listen, I've done
I've said nothing yet. If you run, I will support
you and I will throw a bunch of money behind you.
If you're Ron DeSantis and you've got a bunch of
wealthy Republicans who are telling you that you
could reasonably end up thinking, I'm going to get
the money to catch up, fine. Trump's leading, but
it's March of 2023. The primary isn't really going
to be until June, July of 22, May, June, July,
April, May, June, July of 2024. I have plenty of
time, and with a bunch of this Republican money,
I could actually catch up. That's a possibility.
We have to be honest that this is not nearly as
competitive as some commentators are making it
out to be. It's early and the polls can fluctuate.
Sure. But this is a unique situation where you
have a former president running in a primary.
A former president running in a primary will have
fewer. Are fluctuations the normal. So while Ron
DeSantis certainly could grow his support if he
gets into this race, my instinct is that that
support is going to grow more from picking off
ones and twos and threes from people who have very
little support or even seven like Nikki Haley in a
recent poll than it is from eating away at Trump's
support. That's my prediction. I'm terrible at
predicting things and you should not make any
financial bets based on what I'm telling you. But
that's my instinct right now. It cannot be denied
that it is not as close today as many in the media
are making it seem. I also have expressed to you,
if DeSantis announces and it becomes a national
campaign, DeSantis is total lack of charisma and
seeming commitment to, quote, take the high road,
even though he just comes off as low energy when
he does it. I don't think are going to help
him. So I struggle to see how if it is Trump
versus DeSantis in a long Republican primary.
I just don't know how to. Santos takes it.